Germany if you look at the majority of
what Germany's doing and I could talk
about the specific instance of luzarod
as well
we've we're moving forward with the
transformation of the energy system to
80 Renewables by 2030 the instance of
this case was a very difficult one
where the the chance there was or the
moment was to have an earlier phase out
of coal in North Rhine was failure a
very cold intensive area from 20 38 to
2030 and keep 280 million tons of coal
in the ground and so the very difficult
decision that the government and the on
the regional and the national level made
was to move forward with that and there
is a lot of great ambitious projects
that Germany is doing as you've
mentioned but has it washed away that
opportunity has it damaged that
reputation by expanding this one Coal
Mine these are the very challenging
societal debates that one has to have if
you're serious about moving forward on
the climate crisis I think that there is
enough if you look at what is happening
across the board of phasing out all
Russian Imports of fossil fuels in a
very short period of time 55 percent of
natural gas if you look at the biggest
and energy bill ever passed in Germany
for Renewables accelerating the pace of
permits those were all the things that I
think make up the whole picture you've
mentioned some of the ways that Germany
has rapidly responded to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine Russia's latest
invasion
and the and the consequent energy crisis
was Germany uniquely vulnerable to that
crisis because of its Reliance on gas
and on Russian gas
Germany was definitely vulnerable I
think you can we've learned the hard way
that one shouldn't be so dependent on
fossil fuels or on one country or
dependent on fossil fuels as a whole for
so much of your economy and I think
that's what's led us to work quickly to
diversify to and to build up our own
energy resources as quickly as possible
so that we don't come into that
situation again